c'est en petit comité et en respectant
les gestes barrières que sophie schmidt
a fêté son anniversaire cette année le 3
avril 2020 pendant le premier
confinement c'est en solitaire qu'elle
avait passé cette journée
quand j'ai appris que à nouveau on était
art confiné de manière un peu plus
strictes j'ai vraiment été contrariés la
dernière c'était pire est-ce qu'il va on
n'avait vraiment pas le droit de se
déplacer et même les enfants qui sont
donc dans un autre cas titre quartier de
versailles ne sont pas venus donc on a
fait ça en visio ce 3 avril 2021 en
plein troisième confinement seule la
famille étaient conviés à un déjeuner
couvre-feu oblige en moindre mal pour
fêter comme il se doit ses 54 ans on a
invité mes enfants qui habitent
versailles dans un autre quartier ma
mère qui est du chesnay et puis mes
nièces aussi qu'ils sont l'art sayez à
houdan julia bientôt quatre ans va elle
aussi connaître son deuxième
anniversaire qu'on finit le 15 avril
2020 la petite fêter ses trois ans et
évidemment cette célébration a été
quelque peu adapté nous avons fait un
petit goûter d'anniversaire le jour même
avec les bougies le gâteau et le soir
même nous avons re fêter l'anniversaire
re souffler les bougies avec un nouveau
gâteau d'autres cadeaux et en mettant en
fait le système de visio avec papa mamie
et mamou le 15 avril prochain julia
fêtera son anniversaire avec son papa et
le week end avec sa maman une façon de
garder un peu de normalité
bien que les grands parents qui vivent
dans d'autres régions ne puisse venir
le plus dur pour elle c'est l'absence
des papys mamies et papys maman parce
que elle a vraiment cette notion de fête
avec sa famille et ça c'est plus dur
pour elle de vivre que ce soit à houdan
ou à versailles en 2020 ou en 2021
question cadeaux là aussi il a fallu
s'adapter à la vie des cadeaux puisque
merci la poste il envoie des colis ça ça
aide beaucoup pour recevoir les cadeaux
à l'année dernière c'est vrai que j'ai
pas aimé k2 forcément en temps et en
heure ce qu'on n'était pas habité
finalement acheté en ligne
cette année c'est vrai que ils ont fait
des achats dans les boutiques du
quartier qui était ouverte dombasle
libraire fleuriste un nom de crise
sanitaire écoulée et deux anniversaires
confinés comme beaucoup d'autres
yvelinois
toutes deux ont désormais un souhait
pour l'année prochaine célébrer leur
naissance
sans être confiné